la serbie connaît un rebond inquiétant
de la pandémie de coronavirus le pays de
sept millions d'habitants fait face à
une recrudescence du virus
plus de 30 villes ont déclaré l'état
d'urgence car le nombre de cas de kobe
19 ne cesse d'augmenter ces derniers
jours 350 médecins serbes ont décidé de
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
regroupés sous l'appellation unis contre
le kobe édiles ont adressé ce mardi une
lettre ouverte au gouvernement pour
réclamer le limogeage de sa cellule de
crise l'abandon total des mesures de
lutte contre l'épidémie dans la période
pré électorale a provoqué la perte de
contrôle de la situation épidémiologique
et ne peut être justifiée par des motifs
professionnels
la cellule de crise avait déjà reconnu
que le nombre de morts était très
certainement plus élevé mais elle a tenu
à balayer ces nouvelles critiques
chacun a le droit d'avoir son opinion
toute aide est la bienvenue
il est plus facile de critiquer mais
nous n'avons pas encore reçu des
propositions concrètes
nous sommes ouverts à tous à toute forme
d'aidé de soutien car nous devrions
vraiment agir comme une seule équipe
les hôpitaux désignés pour les cas de
kobe 19 en serbie fonctionnent tous à
leur capacité maximale
la capitale belgrade à elle rouvert son
hôpital temporaire pour les patients
atteints de corona virus